right so it's uh
10 20 so you can just start whenever
you're ready
okay good luck thank you
um hi everyone uh i'm naheed
and i'm with you from toronto canada
tonight
actually today i'm talking to the future
uh
i'm a back-end developer specialized on
application architecture
um we today we're going to talk about
common mistakes and misconceptions in
web application security using oauth 2
and open id connect you can find
my contact info on the screen in case
you wanted to
connect which i will be very happy to
uh and i'm currently a software
architect and
in mcafee um as about me
uh in the next 60 minutes
we're going to talk about the specs and
olaf to an open id connect
specs i'm going to go over specs which
you may
already be familiar with but
we're going to go over the details and
also
going over some best practices about
this
items and also talk about future of this
concept
following that i will have a quick demo
using i am
identity server for which is an open
source
library for oauth and open id connect
i'll do my best to leave some time for
questions
but you can also reach me over
slack for a question for chad i'll be
very happy to
i'm very passionate about security
concepts and
i consider myself learning all the time
so then feel free to just
reach out to chad
so one second
okay let's get started
uh let's talk about authentication and
authorization
these are the two of the main problems
on modern
uh web applications they uh like
authentication is about
who you are that's like verifying the
user
to make sure that this is the this is
who they say they are
and also authorization is about what you
can do
it's like uh this process deals with
granting or denying
rights to access resources like
as an example just imagine an
application which is managing the data
on behalf of the user
so this application should do
authentication to make sure the user is
who they say they are and also needs to
make sure
this user who are who they are
so they can access just the data that
they are allowed to
which means to authorize the user
here is a big picture of how modern
applications may look like
and um so in this picture you can
you see like different scenarios like
for example browsers communicate with
web applications
and browser-based applications
communicate uh with web apis
also like native applications
communicate with the web api
server-based
or new no ui application like device sas
uh and connect with the web apis also
like web applications connecting to the
web apis
uh as their as themselves or on behalf
of the user also web apis can
communicate with each other again as
their own
or as uh or sometimes on behalf of the
user
so and typically each and every one of
these
relations that you see they need to
protect resources
which means that they need to implement
authentication and authorization
every time we talk about resources and
protection so both of them are matter we
need to know who is this user
also they need to access just what
we want them to access or what they have
access to
so the solution uh for these is
oauth2 and open id connect so os2
oauth2 is the industry standard protocol
for authorization
it is actually a delegation protocol um
it means that
it's actually letting someone who
controls
a resource allow a software um
application to access that resource
on their behalf means that the user is
owning the data but they are
delegating this uh access to a software
so oauth is um works over https
and also like us can work on devices
apis servers and applications
and the way that it works is using
access tokens rather than credentials
in fact olaf was came to the picture
for delegation and also like to avoid
the
password the anti-pattern open id
connect
is uh the standard open standard
for the authentication this is the most
recent this is not the first one
uh the federation identity and also like
samal and now open id connect open id
connect
in fact is a single identity layer on
the top of
all us and it actually extends
to for authentication scenarios
so if you're interested to know oawasu
is being developed
uh with the oauth working group
of ietf which is internet engineering
task force
but open id connect specification is
developed by open id
working group these are two uh
different like organizations but they
are connected
now that we know the problems we said
that the problems are
uh authentication authorization and also
we saw the big picture right
and now let's look at that big picture
with the solutions right
so as you see on each of those lines i
draw that
like how open id connect or olaf too can
come to the picture
and uh solve our problems right so if
you see at the top like at the top there
is authorizations that were added as
well so
we're gonna get deeper into this that
how this has to work right so
but uh to to go through let's say
i mean i want to say that all through
and open id connect are actually open
standards means that anyone can
implement it
there is no actual implementation
proposed it's like there is different
libraries and providers
and that but the specs is providing us
the
standard right so and these are actually
fundamentally very complicated
so which may lead to so many mistakes
and
misconceptions on implementation uh
so specs are more than like 400 pages uh
if i certified and um also
like the point is that these specs are
not written for developers
who are using those libraries right
specs are written for people who are
writing the library
or the providers the services which
are which there is so many of them in
the market
as well and as well as open sources so
that's why
specs are not that simple to read as a
developer who is trying to actually use
those libraries
so let's discuss some of the details of
this
specs and also going through the best
practices for this
uh to be able to actually go through
that we need
like let's let's talk about the
terminology like some of these keywords
that is all over the place that
what does this mean so in oh like i'm
gonna
start with uh olaf the reason is that
as we said open id connect is in fact
an extension on the top of ola so if we
do i know like everybody
is interested you know authentication
and an authorization
but in fact because of an id connect is
on the top of olaf
it's for the best if you learn this back
if you learn the details of
olaf and then say now like the extension
for authentication works like this
uh so let's start with the roles so
when we talk about the rules on uh oauth
so there is some keywords that they may
seem very complicated like research on
there like
um which resource owner or ro
is the user is a person who is doing
actually
that delegation it's like uh
which is end user if if the client
actually
it can be end user so the resource
server
is the api right it's hosting the
protected resources
and also it's capable of accepting
and responding to protected resources
uh requesting uh by the by this
access token so it's like in like in
simple word
research server is the service that
exposes that data
right so then it's api like in most of
scenarios when we talk about resources
we're just talking about the api client
client is actually
the application it's the application
making protected the
resource requests on behalf of the user
so on behalf of that resource owner that
we just
talked about and the
term client can and can be like a
web application device and even an api
and the first one is the authorization
server or as
so the authorizations server is uh the
component
which is issuing the access token to the
client
after uh successfully authenticating the
resource owner and
also uh obtaining the authorization
right
so after making sure that uh this is
valid
this is the one that um
issuing the token so the authorization
server you might
um see it as a security token service as
well which is like
sts like these are the same if you saw
the same keyword
um the next uh
thing in the terminology is the client
type
before i talk about client type i should
say the client
that we talked about so for a client
like it has
two uh property so each client
has a unique identifier which we call
client id
it's a public identifier um for the apps
and uh it's like a random string sorry
but it's suggested to not be
uh guessable very easily right and
another property that the client has is
a client secret
and the secret is known only to the
client
to this application and also to
authorization server
so again it's a random string but it's
better not
to be guessable and it's for the best to
use like
like cryptography secure libraries to
generate that's
that secret
so the reason i said that because now
the type of client
is related to that uh security to that
um secret right so the first type of
clients are confidential client
so confidential clients are the ones
that can
actually keep that secret secure so
they and they are like able to securely
authenticate with the authorization
server right like um
i'm gonna provide some examples of this
and uh the public client
but is not like that they are unable uh
to hold this secret secure
right it's like um
like as an example the small apps mobile
apps and devices
are public clients so they are running
on the browser
on the internet and also like uh devices
are owned by a user so there is a user
they have like a smart tv imagine their
smart tv it's
in people's houses right so i know it
sounds very very hard but it
is not impossible that somebody read the
content
that we upload on the tv also like
because
user has the ownership they can actually
read the wi-fi
uh communication or something like this
which means that they are not
um confidential right they are
considered public line and for
confidential like apis like
web applications like an nvc web
application which is on the server
uh there is a another type of client
which they call
credential clients just as an extension
and which
uh is more of a future concept
so it's like they have credentials uh
but then because
it's it's they are mostly dynamically
registered
so then it means that the authorization
server cannot
confirm their identity it's just just as
a side note just to know
like there is a third type as well
uh so here comes to the first note
so i decided to just show the
notes like the best practices or stuff
like that we learned we have to focus
more
by this lamp and the devices are public
client
so this is a matter because in so many
of examples they just
introduce devices or smart tvs as a
confidential
the next thing in the terminology is the
scopes
scopes initially propose the concept of
a scope
by oauth2 so scopes are used to express
what an application can do on behalf of
a given user
and it's always scopes are subset of
what
a user can do in the first place right
so uh so then they are just for handling
delegation
and on behalf of the user
and because of that as we said that
scripts
are subs of what user can actually do
scopes cannot allow an application to do
more than what the user can do
right and the other like here and
i have some example of the scopes like
for example you can say order write
order delete or they're read so which
these are like user can delegate order
write to this application so
an application can just make an order
instead of like in
on behalf of the user the other concept
is consent the concept is
like the application can request
one or more scopes this information then
later presented to the user in the
consent screen
and so then the user
can actually limit those scopes right
and say like for example like
application is asking or even they have
registered i mean they have access to
application have access to or the right
order delete but
then on the content users say i don't
want this application to be able to
delete this order
right so most of you already seen the
consent
form especially like when you try to log
in using
social media which is more of open id
connect or
authentication but the same concept so
in general
the scopes that that an application is
requesting
can be modified by um resource on air by
the user and
also authorization server both of them
can actually
modify the scopes there is a tip
about scopes which is very important
because um in general there is no
standard i mean the specs doesn't say
about the scopes in fact like um
scopes like the the access token
i mean they can be not be in access
token slogan can contain no
scope but like yeah that's why like it's
um
best practices about scopes that is say
that
scopes alone in an access token are not
enough to carry
on authorization decisions so it means
that
like it's they are not enough so it's on
the application to actually
mix the scopes with um
with the with what user can do with user
privileges to decide about permissions
right later in the demo i'm going to
show you
a sample of this that how they should be
this is a very important um
and olaf does not define any particular
values for scopes
since it's highly dependent on services
internal architecture
and needs but it is suggested
um that scopes does not carry the
permission
alone right so they have to be mixed
with with user privilege to decide about
permissions
on the api's speciality
and the next thing is access tokens
so access token is like as we said oauth
is about delegation of the access
using access token instead of
credentials right so
then this is one of the actual main
concept of the oauth
so access tokens are the things that
application
used to make api requests on behalf of
user
and so again for access token on olaf
there is no defined structure
and that is required by factories best
practices for that but
it's not required right it's it's like
it the specs say that access token
should be an opaque string means that
like it should
not be transparent to the user right and
it can be any random string
uh bear tokens are actually the most
common type of
uh or predominant type of uh access to
confused
within oauth too um but
the spec doesn't require to do that
right
so um here i have an
example of a access token which is a jwt
jwt or json web token some people call
it jot
is an open standard they have it has an
rfc for itself which define a compact
and also self-contained
way for securely transmitting the
information between parties as a json
object
like in simple word it's a way to just
send the json object
uh here and there in a secure way right
and this information on
jwt token can be
verified and trusted because it is
digitally signed
so on best practices it suggests that
you use jwt
for the access token but if you see um
on the screen
so i'm gonna try to actually
um i hope it's big enough so
uh this is this screen that you see
i tried to like decode a
jwt token using jwt io
it's just a website and uh so if you see
each data ability has three parts the
header the payload
and also the signature right so what we
talked about um
their scopes and you can see in the
payload it's the content of this token
and um in the in the signature
so that's you see the signature of this
that you say it's
a sign and it's secure so but what i
wanted to actually
talk about is the header as well so on
the best practices
it is suggested to if you to use jwt in
the first place
and also using typed one so if you see
the token that i have there
it say 80 plus jwt as a type means that
this is a
access token which is jwt it means that
if i have another jwt token
i can recognize which one is access
token and later when we
get to identity token you will see that
i want the type
gonna be different so then i can say
which token is what
this is um suggested to do so
and um yeah
uh so here as a tip i have it um locked
a little bit to just make sure um we do
that so to use type
json web token as a best practice to do
okay so in general json web tokens
um are suggested because of consistency
as well
because it is consistent to use
everywhere and also they are
self-contained
so when you use gwt you there is no need
to round trip to authorization server to
verify but if you use a random string
right
to verify that the api it has to be a
round trip
to the uh authorization server
to make sure that this is valid or
figure out some other way to just
validate that token
the other tip about jw tokens which is
very important
is that the jw tokens
can be verified without doing a database
look up around crypto authorization
server as we said
so that's why there was no way to
invalidate the token until it expires
so it means that like like if you have a
token
so this token is up the client and um
like client might might make like a
couple of calls to the apis
so even if it's um invalid right even if
you decide to invalid that the
ways there is a standard to invalidate
talking and things
but uh like if you don't implement
other things or don't do in simple way
there is no way to invalidate it that's
why i suggested to use
a short term token not like because some
of the software they use
um token for like a week or two so then
it is if it's in the wrong hand so then
you're gonna be in trouble i mean
the application gonna be in trouble
the next concept to go through is the
endpoints under
oauth2 we have we have multiple
endpoints but
two of the main ones that we're going to
discuss here
is the authorization endpoint and also
token input
so authorization endpoint which is the
first one is
um used to interact with the resource
owner
and obtain the authorization grant so
uh and big on this authorization server
first
actually verify the identity of this
resource owner to make sure
like it is a valid one i'll show an
example of
um how this work but also the token
and after that the token emblem token
and point is the one which is actually
used to obtain access token um
here is uh here i have example of
audrey's uh
authorized endpoint so about the request
that how does it work to do alter
endpoint which is a get so you send the
client id
scopes and then the response type
and um the rudolph url
so it's just a sample thing to how it
works so
when we get to the grants so we're gonna
talk about
more details but here it's just to say
that in the terminology there is an
authorized
endpoint which is saying what grant to
use and here is the token endpoint um
like um example of the post to token and
point about the request and also like
the response on the on the left you see
the request
which is um to the token endpoint the
information required
and also on the right on the top the
successful response and below you're
going to see the error response
and if you see the ax on the top uh top
right we have
access we have actually token response
which contains access token token type
and
and also reference token expires in so
within this the access token and token
and type are the mandatory one the
x-partisan
is recommended but the rest are optional
and um
like can be not there
and for the for the errors there is
different errors involved
like invalid request is an example like
you can have invalid decline in valid
grant and but this is the standard to
how to get the response which is
very actually descriptive
here i have a high-level uh
diagram of how this works now we know
these keywords in the tech terminology
now when you see the resource owner you
know that this is the user when you see
the
authorization server and when you see
resource server and also client you know
that
you would know that this is the
application which is asking
for a resource right so this is
very very high level just to show how
the round trips to this
to to each other is happening but uh
we're gonna go
further to the mall and to the details
of the grant this is just
to give you a picture of how in general
in the
high level in abstract tanks work
grant types for the grant types actually
grants are
and are the flows are the solutions for
different use cases
uh it's like i have this use case for
example i have a mobile app okay what's
the solution
with olaf i have like uh web app what is
the solution or what's gonna
um suggest to me right
uh for this if you see i have them with
different ones right
so you see client credentials and but
you see authorization code and password
and implicit in different font
because some of these are legacy grants
and they are not suggested to use
and we're going to discuss like um the
ones that are not legacy
with more details actually and um
let's let's go to client credentials as
a first one
so line credentials is um
the grant type or is the flow as you see
in the picture
um it's it's a flow that client
is asking is is authenticating it's
uh sending their client id and client
secret
and then they're gonna get an access
token to be able to
call an api and based on this sample you
see that there is a client secret
involved right
this means that um this this must be
confidential client right
so and this is true this um grant type
is to obtain access token for
for a client but out of the scope of
user this is not on behalf
when we had that big picture we said
okay sometimes this web application or
this api they want to um
access each other but they don't want to
do that on behalf of user this is the
grant suggested for that
this grant is suggested for server to
server as we discussed
and also for confidential client for
this grant as well like
access token can be any string but it is
suggested the best practices for this
grant
is to use json web token as well because
like even if you do the call and not on
behalf of the user but you do to the
same
api right if if if we talk and if we
use another access access token type and
not the jwts
so then we need another code and other
infrastructure to be able to read
that access token as well but just in
favor of
consistency it's suggested to use json
web token for this as well
and also https i know this is server to
server
but honestly https is the only thing
protecting requests from being
intercepted or modified
so that's why it is suggested so let's
go to the next one
authorization code grant authorization
code grant we said
it is legacy and it is suggested to not
to use it
but authorization code grant is actually
based for the pixie pixy is the next one
that we said okay
it's not legacy that's why it's good if
we go through this
and i want to go through this and say
why it is suggested not to use it
and then now the the one that is
suggested to use it uh
what it is so on the left you see a
high-level diagram which shows how
authorization code grant works so um
it is used let's say by confidential and
also public
client to exchange it's based on
exchange authorization code
for access token so first the
client is um requesting a code
from the authorization server and then
gonna exchange it for the access token
right then there is
there is two um two process
involved here so this brand is using
front channel
to use to get the access token which is
the less secure one
and then it uses the back channel to
exchange this code
with the act and with access token which
is the highly secure way to get that
all right and also in this uh in this
grant what we do is that we are sending
the return url as well
like we say that when we ask for the
code we say
and this is the redirect url and then so
this redirect url is what i'm gonna
redirect you and also it's registered
for client
if i want to go through that again from
the top after this description i would
say that okay like the client is
at is going to authorization server
using their identifier
if they are confidential using um yeah
using actually they're just on the
identifier and then and they say
this is my redirect url and with this
redirect url
client is already registered on the
authorization server
means that there is another check that
this authorization so we're going to
check that redirect url is
mapped and it's correct and also they
will send this estate
which is for um like cross site
request forgery attack actually but it's
not tied to the code
what is happening on the front channel
the authorization server gonna redirect
back
to the client with the code right
and then after that client gonna request
again
so you see on the uh right below that it
would go to now to the token endpoint
and say
okay now exchange this code that i have
right i received in the previous um step
with this uh with my with an access
token
just exchanges with access token and
it's gonna send the real requirement
again
right it would say okay so that was it
and also
like for the confidential client it
would send the secret as well
so but secret not for the public lines
so for confidential
client so this um
flow was actually
this flow was actually was originally
requested for mobile applications right
but there was uh there was like a couple
of attacks which was
re reported on this flow that's why they
said don't use it let's see what was
those attacks
so the first attack which was was
authorization code
interception attack so this was for
public clients
so which was reported absolutely the
document that i have is
for smartphones is for uh phone
applications
so in the uh for the public lines as i
said we don't have any secret
right so then as long as somebody
grab that code somebody can access that
code they can
they can just go and exchange that with
the
authorization server so on their
smartphones
um like just imagine i have
an app and then i have a malicious app
right this malicious app
is just registering itself under the
same with our qrl
correct and then after like
when when when the authorization code is
back
the the operating system browser
might return to the malicious app or to
the legitimate
app right if the mill each of those can
happen that's why it is not a
full line so and then if the malicious
app received that
so they can exchange for the access
token right they don't even need to be
like a copy of that app they can be any
app right
as long as they can be there on that
smartphone and they register themselves
on the same
return url redirect url so
they will work and then they exchange so
i know you might discuss that there was
a state
uh like uh parameter but it's not tied
to the code
in the authorization code and this was
just for public clients right
there was and you might say okay now for
confidential
so why not using that so there is
another attack which called
authorization code injection attack it's
it's a more complex attack
but um in fact this one is like just
imagine
it is actually happening from a
legitimate client
right so um on the authorization code
injection
so i have a client so which is the user
the user try to log in
and then i like him just imagine there
is like a
browser extension on their machine or
something that when they try to log in
when they receive
actually that code back now
that that like malicious uh
like extension gonna grab that code
right and send it to the
attacker attacker in fact has
a client which is legitimate client
right
but then they don't have the username
password of this user right
so just imagine this user is already
authenticated and everything but they
want to have the same access that this
user has
what they would do is to just get that
code
okay this is confidential client they
need secret that's why they use
a legitimate client so so they would use
this code
we and from the same app from the
their client they try to initiate
authorization code grant
they would go to the server and then
once they receive the code instead of
for the next
step instead of they and try to exchange
code
with access token with their own code
they will replace
that and the user code with that and
then they exchange
this attack is called authorization code
injection
means that it's not even from a
malicious app or malicious client
it's from a legitimate client but we and
we didn't
i mean use an attacker is using that
it's not our actual user using that
that's why it is such as that um to do
not use
authorization code grant and use pixi
but what is this pixel
so pixi is a proof
key code exchange uh it it
there was an rfc on 2015 i guess
for pixie so pixie is here to fix that
problem the problems that
we talked about and this pixie is to
fix that but how it's trying to fix that
just imagine
for the pixie um to when we use pixi for
public clients um so
like um um it does the same right for
public and confidential
it will receive the code and then it
would exchange the code
with their access token but what it does
it hasn't it has actually just imagine
like we said that for confidential
they would use the secret uh to exchange
the
code with the access token right the
secret is to guarantee that hey this is
the client
but then uh the attacker would actually
attack that as well with just uh doing
using their legitimate client
but here on pixi this um this
this secret is like a like imagine a
dynamic secret
way right it's just that on each request
on each of this um
flow the full one it's like there is the
authentication is happening
why because the mechanism is in a way
that when
and just just imagine this client as a
code verifier which is a random string
right just
they would say okay i want this um i
have this um
like random stream that i generated so
when i want to on the front channel i'm
asking for the code right
i go to authorization server i'm going
to send the request to the client id
redirect uri
and the other things which was already
on authorization code flow
but along with that i'm gonna actually
send them this uh
code verifier and also um then
but but in a way with a method i'm gonna
like for example hash it right
so then i want to i they name it code
challenge means that
it's the code verifier which is hashed
or
secured but then also the method that
is sent to right so now i'm sending
a random string with the metal that i
generated this random string
to the authorization server right so
authorization server
is getting that and then and later when
i received the code it would already
back to me and then i
received the code so now with that when
i'm asking like when the client is
asking for
the to exchange this access token
they're gonna send the actual code
verifier now right the code verifier the
the random string that they had without
hashing or encrypting
or doing any cryptography
like function on that right they would
send the actual one
so in the first one the
the challenge center which is the
modified
code verifier the the encrypted one
and in the second one the actual code
verifier means that
authorization server now has a chance to
check
yes this is the same one why because
they received the method
and me before and also code challenge
now with that code verifier when it's
sent they can apply the same method on
the code verify
to make sure these two are the same
right um
so that's why there is guarantee that
the same client
which actually requested the code and
received the code
is the same client is exchanging the
access token with us
that's why it's secure and it is i just
said for the previous attack reason that
we talked suggested to use pixie for
both um public and also a confidential
club
there were some tips um about pixi
um so this is um like
as we said for a stolen authorization
code attack and also
um code injection so there is
a very good tip about pixi as well so
which actually can
um we can be in trouble if we do that so
which is the reoric uri so
rhetoric url must your way must be
compared using exact string match for
the pc
so this is a good tip um to do that
so imagine like this is an example that
can go wrong
like if you register because some of the
providers actually letting you do that
so if you for example register the first
one
so that the attacker can go with the
third one and
just um return back like as a readable
url
can receive your code so
it it actually helps to detect mix-up
attack
um so it's it would take very long to
explain weeks of attack but it's
good to know that rudolph you are well
gonna help us on that
also do not use referral http header
so even if you use pixi so do not use
refer http headers this is in the best
practices
because if you use um http like
referrers the leakage can happen from
like oauth client and also authorization
server
um so like like just imagine
when you receive code or or even the
access token
if you have a link out into that in that
page
on somewhere else it can cause leakage
okay so i'm not gonna go deep into how
the location work
um so the password grant
and um there is a password grant
and implicit or to off
legacy one so i guess i'm gonna skip
those
um so but they are on the deck you can
go over them i'm gonna share the deck
actually but the best practices
say um use pixie instead of those
and also implicit grant so implicit
grant
just just let's say implicit grant is
was suggested for the
javascript applications uh because
like at 2012 like the
we wouldn't be able to actually make a
goal from javascript to
another domain right so that's why they
simplified
authorization code flow and they
suggested to use this implicit grant but
this is not the case we have a
course and the solution is there it's
not
suggested to use this anymore because
now we can do ajax call
um to outs to other domains and this is
not the case anymore so that's why it is
suggested to use pixi insta
so now if we come go back to the
terminology
so um it's better to say that okay here
and like just when client credentials
are and pixie are the ones
to be used
so reference token is the last thing on
the
oauth so it means that um
so for for the reference token if when
you receive an access
token uh and this token is expired so
when you use it invalid token
so you like refresh showcase to have to
to have a chance to just ask for a new
access token right um so
for the confidential clients already
when you ask for a refresh token when we
are actually requesting
um the secret but not
for public clients so that's why for the
public clients the best practices
say that use um send their constraint
refresh tokens or do the refresh talking
rotations
so this is um suggested like um center
so here i have that so sender constraint
refresh token is to tie this reference
token to the client just to make sure
the same client who had the access token
with the refresh token
is actually requesting for the reference
token and
one-time use is actually it suggests
that it's um
it's um suggests i mean in the future
it's gonna be in the
uh spec so it's just in case that things
go wrong
and the attacker received actually a
refresh token
so just make sure that it's used one
time right
and even if the legitimate client who
didn't accept
didn't receive that request i mean
like the reference token was used but
this client which had that because of
one time
like um they wouldn't be able to use
that that's okay just
it's one client and there there was an
attack so
then it's better to know and stuff just
doing nothing
so here i have some use cases
which show um like what is the
like we talked about authorization and
out and authentication here i have
something to just convince you that we
need authentication
uh here so uh for the delegate
delegated authorization yes it is
authorization but then when we talk
about
spa law games bob logging mobile app and
single sign-on these are all
authentication cases right something is
um
is required and all of the is not for
authentication the reason it's safe
because
so like we talked about like highlights
in the terminology right we just
skipped the detail but like here there
was no standard way to get user info we
didn't talk about
actually uh user info
also like every implementation for
authentication is different yeah some
people use them
federation authentication saml but then
there is no
there was no like standard for that
and also like there was no um
common sense of scope actually for uh
like this user info or or just to say
what is data about this
user that's why actually open id connect
came to picture so this is so
this is actually the most recent um
standard
or technology for authentication but uh
this is hand to hand with
all of us too and as we said it
is an extension on the top of our work
as i try to demonstrate in a simple very
simple way
um that it is on the top it's an
extension on the top of a wasp too
and it uses all of all all that
and then i'm gonna get there actually in
a bit
uh so uh on open id connect
there is a couple of new concepts added
right
um in the terminology so first of all on
um about this like i'm gonna just talk
about the things which is added not the
things which are shared like uh when
like on uh open id connect when we read
the spec
we we see a concept as a relying party
right
relaying party or rp which is actually
the client
right this is a client which accept
which would support open id connect
so then like the same client that we
talked if it supports um
open id connect they call it rp index
back
and op or open id provider again it's an
authorization server which is capable of
authenticating the user and providing um
the
claims related to this authentication to
relaying party so then these terms is
actually
this is like authorization server and
client but like in this spec they just
um
have different names right so here is a
high level of
how open id connect works right in the
high level it's just um they
um like um relaying party asking for
authentication asking like them
you know open id provider asking for
authentication
and then um having that back
and then like it's the rest like like
having a identity talking
or eventually accident access token back
and also
asking for the user info like here all
over the place you see the
user info because like yes this is one
of the things added we're going to get
to the end point um sorry i'm trying to
go to faster pace because i'm um
checking the time and i still have a lot
to say so
for um the scopes actually it's
one of the things which is on which is
special about open id characters that
there was no common
uh or standard scope about users or
authentication in the oauth right but um
open id connect it comes that um
like it say that yes there is a standard
the scopes can be used to request
some specific setup information and
make about user and make them available
on claim values this is the big
difference constant is the same
so but the difference that on the
constant on open id connect when we show
the constant
so we don't say do we want them to you i
mean we don't say if
that's the case too but we say okay user
and user do you want me to
return this information of you to this
application
so then it's it's a bit um difference
now when you have
just oauth and then when you add open id
connect it's actually added to that
in addition what to do also what to
expose to this application would matter
and also like um as a tip like open id
scope is mandatorian or kinetic connect
there is another concept which is an
id token so which is an open id connect
as an id token
it's again a jwt token which contains
claims about
the authentication event right so
and it might it may contain other claims
as well but now you see that
it has information about when
authentication happened
and then when the id token issued
and things like that but in olaf token
there was no
information about this and if you see
uh like um the top now i have actually
a an id um id token on the screen
if you see the top and the type it's now
jwt like we had
eight tip loss gwg right so if i have
two tokens
right so this one is identity token the
other one was access token right
and here like in the playload you can
see like um properties which
are related to the authentication just
happened right
um and it's not just about scopes which
are for
authorization for delegation of access
so uh
and so when we come to open id connect
there is more endpoints added
so the main one which i said user
rainfall we saw user info here and
they're everywhere that um
this is actually one of the things added
for openid connect
and this is an endpoint can be used to
retrieve identity information about the
user in the high level diagram when we
sold
is that the relay party actually gonna
ask for
uh authentication and after that can ask
for user info right this end point and
this was what was uh missing in the olaf
right we needed something to know okay
this user who logged in who was that
user
and also discovery endpoint you might
see
this um in the open id
connect providers so it retains
information like
issuer name keymad or materials and
supported the scopes like most of them
has this this is in the spec
um so this is a example of uh
user info endpoint and um if you see
like for user user info endpoint
we need to send the access token right
and to be able to access that which
means it's authorized
and um a sample of the results is like
that i get
actually information about this user
like um
as many as user uh letters to return
right
give consent to turn so on
open idconnect terminology is a game so
we
it was um authorization code implicit
as well but for the same reasons
actually the
exact same reasons they are they are not
suggested to be used
but pixi and um hybrid
is the ones that are safe so i'm gonna
quickly go
through the hybrid one so and hybrid
grant is
um of uh like the pixie is exactly like
how we describe that right
so the only difference about pixi is
that
we are actually sending the we are
sending the openid scope as well
to the authorization server or openid
provider
and then after that that's the
authorization server
which is now open id provider which can
handle that and
challenge that and um like showing their
login
to the user which means a centralized
login that's that's actually
one of the biggest purposes to do that
to have that right
so then if this authorization server is
open id connect provider
so the only thing you need to do is just
send open id
scope and the hybrid one hybrid is
actually good to know
about that and so hybrid is safe but uh
so for hybrid
what we do is that we're gonna receive
an authorization code flow we're gonna
receive id token
uh um in addition of the code right and
then we exchange that code for the
access token
but there is a difference here in which
they call it hybrid and the hybrid there
is a property you see here as a c
hash is actually the hashed version of
code
so which means that when client receive
that it's gonna compare this
this hashed version um
and it received the code and it's gonna
do the hash
the code and it's gonna compare them to
make sure that
um it is the same to just make it secure
right
but downside to this is that so as you
see because we said on the front channel
it's going to receive code plus id token
means that id token is
perceived as a in front channel
which is not secure so it might leak
additional personal
like information about user that you
don't want to right
also like um this mitigation stuff that
we talked about this um
thing that compares c hash with the code
is that it is actually need to be
implemented on the client
which results to more complicated client
library which is not
suggested much um and it's better to
handle everything
like on the server not on the client so
that's why i suggested to use
uh authorization code plus pixie
or pixi for all clients
here i have some use cases i have the
these
use cases like it's a web app native
mobile app and spa
all of them is suggested to use pixi
these are the
this is like we tried to explain why uh
i hope i i try i could convince you and
for api for service
and server to server communication to
access and to
receive access the client authorization
is what is suggested
so i have actually a couple of
this um this these are in my deck it's
about best practices about
spots and native apps that i'm not sure
that
we have time to go through that
so um okay i wanted to do a demo i have
like five minutes so
i'm going to show you a quick demo
so here
all right i would need to
stop presenting and then represent
so here i have an application
well something happened with my words
sorry
um here i have um
an application which is which i wanna
[Music]
show you actually um like uh different
scenarios using
um identity server for which is
an open source uh library for openid
connect
and also oauth so i just want to show
you quickly
oh it was here uh i want i want to show
you
quickly that like all the stuff that we
talked about
how like how easy would be to if we use
the right
library if we use the right uh
provider right i'm gonna share this code
um
because i'm not sure if i can just um
show to you everything so i have
this uh like all the scenarios here at
listed but
unfortunately because a rough time we
couldn't do that
so here like um let me show you a
very quick demo of this
client authorization flow
in this model what i have is that i have
in this model i have a identity server
project
so which is a authorization server for
oauth and also
its open id connect provider right
um so this one like here to be able
uh to implement that so what is
so i have a client registered here so
this client
is as easy as a console application so
here
all i said was that now i have this
client
and this client is the console app
so i'm gonna do client credentials and
it has a secret because it's a
confidential and also i say that what is
this course that i want
this application to
have access to and now like uh
on my application on the same client
thing
so just um like i'm gonna receive a
token
so using let me show you the code
so here receiving token
is as simple as just make a call to this
authorization server
that i have okay and just say give me
a token for this and just say this is my
client and this is the scopes that i
want to access to
and that's all and i'm gonna have a
token
which later with this token i can call
an api
but then this this call is not on behalf
of any user
this calls actually on like this console
app is doing the call
and look at this so
now i'm trying to receive the token
right this is my token
and then i called this api so on this
api this is often like olaf
uh information received so
which called an api so now i'm going to
call
like a delete api see like because of
the
access issue now i had i didn't have
access i'm charged
another token and now i have that
thing let me show you what was that
not access like look at this now i'm
trying to
like call an api with different scopes
just to demonstrate
how the scopes are working right so and
here i am like um this is this is what
actually i wanted to show you
so here i have an api so look at this
api
like this i'm not sure i'm not showing
you actually how the
how to write the code on an api or how
to do an endpoint it's just to
demonstrate how the things are working
so this is my api i'm gonna share my
code so remember with the tip that
we talked about scopes right i said that
scopes
are saying what access right but we said
that this this
is the api that at the end need to
decide about permission right
so here to demonstrate that i have this
api
so which is like me like i wanted to say
that okay
now this is the api and just the user
can do that right
so i go here and i say okay like um
call this user account when i come here
for this
so i would check if you see here there
is no name for this identity means that
it wasn't
on behalf of a user right just just to
show that so here like i'm gonna
just return that means that on this api
uh with the scope the scope was full
when we called this
like i had like write and delete and
read access
but then because the user is not logged
in we would say
no means that like combining user
privileges
plus desktops that's what i wanted to
show you
okay sorry i'm out of
time
and i'm gonna show you this code it's a
i have um
on this code i have this is repo i'll
show
like i have um client authorization i
have
code authorization with pixi and i have
a javascript line and i have some
some like older like.net for
applications
and using that as well i am and i hope
it will be useful um
sorry i didn't leave any time for
questions
and if if if there is any question so i
guess
uh maybe like for two three minutes
so feel free to ask i'm so sorry if i
talked very fast i tried to
like and there is like the future
remaining so but then i'm gonna have the
slides there and on the slides i i had
this future thing
just to talk but then now i'm gonna do a
modification i'm gonna list them in this
slide then
give you the chance to review those and
yeah
i get so excited myself when i talk
about these concepts and
yeah uh if if there is any question
please feel free to ask me in the slack
channel or even now if there is
something
this is denise here uh i have a question
regarding the attack which we were
talking about on the authorization code
flow
our company is actually uh you know
using oauth and open id connect
heavily and we are we have implemented
hybrid code flow
so you don't think the hybrid also is
prone to the attacks
hybrid code flow is also prone to the
attacks i mean it can be attacked
so the attack that we talked to them no
hybrid
should be good for the authorization
code and for
em like um interception and
also injection no as we talked that um
the hash of the code is actually
providing the attack
so means that this is suggested use
pixie or hybrid but for the hybrid as we
talk
so there is heavier logic on the client
to match this
um encode the encrypted code right
so like yeah yeah but no no like it's
suggested for open id connect
using pixie or hybrid flow but like pixi
is
like a easier one because client is not
involved with
the with the logic okay
thank you yeah
okay i guess we are good thank you yeah
that's good yeah yeah i'm er
yeah okay good yeah no actually
you